- We actually just had
Christina Applegate on.
- [Linda] I watched you guys
that was such a great interview.
- [Kelly] I love her, and I wanted
to bring that up, like if you had
that support system in your life
because she explained that you were
part of the support system in hers
whenever she was diagnosed with MS.
And that's a hard thing to go through.
It's hard thing to watch...
- Yeah
- someone go through.
And she was talking about how hard it was,
like doing the last season,
like and just making it happen.
- [Linda] Yeah.
- What was that experience like for you?
- You know, it's just,
you just hope you can,
you know, nobody wants
to see their friends
or the people they love and care about
go about, you know, go through
anything that is difficult,
or challenging.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Linda] And we always laugh
'cause it kind of looks like
maybe a tampon commercial
(Kelly and audience laugh)
or something.
- This is why I want to call
her and be friends with y'all,
(Linda laughs)
'cause that is something I would say,
but I would find inappropriate.
But you said it, not me.
- I can say that though.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- That's just a
feminine hygiene thing.
- [Kelly] No, I know but it would be
inappropriate if I said it 'cause I'm not
in the photo.
- [Linda] Yeah, yeah yeah. Yes
- But like it's an amazing
after school special
- We can just superimpose you in there
with like a box of tampons.
- [Kelly] Awesome, exactly.
Thank you, I'll be the
Olan Mills on the side.
(Linda giggles)